My name is Hogan Winklemann,
founder of the company called Travelping.
We are entirely focused
on network services
and operator services,
developing software for that,
for many, many years now.
We have the advantage that
the network services we use,
which are doing different
things, and just IT services,
they need to communicate to each other,
and IBM Cloud was the only
platform we can find these days
where we can deploy such
horizontal services in the cloud.
What it means for the
consumer is more speed,
faster downloads, bigger videos, etc.
But this is not the
challenge for the carrier.
The challenge for the
carrier are other use cases
like making a car
communicating to another car
in sub-milliseconds to avoid an accident.
This needs totally different deployment,
architectures, and topologies,
which cannot be solved
by just running a new software release.
So, we need to create
another infrastructure for telco services,
which needs to go into the field
and which needs to be distributed.
The Cloud is the foundation for that.
So, you don't need to start
to mount telco equipment
in own data centers anymore
because 90% of the stack
is available in the Cloud.
You can use resources
wherever you want to go.
This is one of the huge
advantages that global carriers,
or the local carriers can act globally,
but fulfilling the local regulations.
And because a company from Germany
can deploy in South Korea,
which is one example we
have done on IBM Cloud.
And deploying the service
last year in South Korea
was about talking to IMB engineers,
fixing some networking problems for us
and this first, was a great experience.
It's not just an API, it's
also API with a human.
With people helping you
if it's really required.
Just was great.
A major experience,
and we got a service we need.